أريد فقط أن أحصل على رؤيتك حول
ما يمكن أن يحدث في هذه
المفاوضات. من الواضح أن كل ما تعرفه هو أن كل
شيء يتم بهدوء في كار
ولكن إحدى القضايا الرئيسية هي معرفة
من هم الرهائن وما زلنا لا
نملك الوضوح  بشأن ذلك لأن
حماس لا تحملهم جميعًا على حق،
فكيف يؤثر ذلك في
المفاوضات، نعم صباح الخير ماكس،
أعتقد أنك على حق، التحدي هو أن
حماس لا تحملهم جميعًا ولكن كما
تعلم كما تحدثنا  قبل أن يتم
جمع المعلومات من جميع
الرهائن الذين تم إطلاق سراحهم، يتم
استجواب كل واحد منهم من قبل
متخصصين في الاستخبارات، ويتم
تطوير المعلومات لتحديد ومحاولة
تحديد مكان كل من هؤلاء الرهائن
حتى أولئك الذين لم يكونوا حاضرين مع
غيابهم  يشير إلى أنهم
على الأرجح مع مجموعة أخرى لذا
يمكنك تركيز المجموعة على
الجهاد الإسلامي الفلسطيني في تلك المرحلة أه أو
يمكنك التحدث عن أه أي أحاديث
تدور بين الحراس أو
القادة المثليين أثناء احتجازك لذلك كل
هؤلاء  يتم استنباط الأشياء
أثناء الاستجوابات وسنلعب على
الصورة الاستخباراتية أه
يتم إطلاق سراح النساء والأطفال حتى الآن في
مرحلة ما، ستنفد حماس من النساء
والأطفال إذا أمكنني أن أصف الأمر بهذه الطريقة
لإطلاق سراحهم ونحن'  سننتقل
إلى الرجال، أليس كذلك نحن وفي نهاية المطاف
الجنود الذين يخدمون، لذا من المفترض أن
تطلب حماس سعرًا أعلى
لهؤلاء، ربما تمديد الهدنة
أو المزيد من السجناء الفلسطينيين في
المقابل، نعم، لذلك أعتقد أن هذا هو ما
سنذهب إليه  نصل إلى النقطة الشائكة
لسوء الحظ الآن كما تعلمون أنه أمر
عملي وعملي لكلا
الجانبين حماس وأه إسرائيل والمجتمع
الدولي لمحاولة إخراج أكبر عدد ممكن من
الرهائن أم النساء
والأطفال وأعتقد أننا سنحقق ذلك على الأرجح
وأعتقد أن وجود أه
مدير بيرنز من وكالة المخابرات المركزية هناك وهو دبلوماسي
ماهر يعرف أن
المنطقة فعالة للغاية في هذه
المنطقة أه ومع مجموعات مثل حماس أه
أعتقد أن هناك احتمال أننا سنقوم
بتمديدها سنفعل  من المحتمل أن
نخرج جميع النساء والأطفال
وأعتقد أنه من المعقول الاعتقاد بأننا
سنتمكن على الأرجح من إخراج أي شخص يعاني من
حالة طبية أو أصيب
بجراح، لذا آمل أن أرى ذلك
على وجه الخصوص
الأمريكي إتش جولدبيرج بولاند الذي خسر
ذراعه أثناء ذلك ولكن أعتقد أننا
سنصل حقًا إلى نقطة قرار صعبة
بإخراج أه رجال آخرين وجنود جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
لأنك تعلم أن هذه
سلعة لحماس وأه توفر
لهم نفوذ القوة والدروع البشرية
أه وتعطيهم  لهم القدرة على
إطالة أمد هذه
الأزمة